welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this episode is featuring my dear old
dad jordan peterson
because this is an episode with my dad i
thought it'd be appropriate to bring up
a few things
one absolutely huge thing his book
beyond order 12 more rules for life came
out yesterday march 2nd
it's available below or at
jordanbypeterson.com or
on amazon or wherever you buy books
unless they decided to not sell it for
political reasons but most places have
it
because they like money anyway the book
is fantastic
in my opinion i actually like it better
than the first book
in my humble opinion this episode
is brought to you by self-authoring
self-authoring
was developed by my dad over the last 30
years with help from two other phd's at
mcgill and harvard
it has past authoring allowing you to
write out your past
great for trying to work through trauma
although i'd recommend writing about
trauma at minimum a year after it's gone
so you don't re-traumatize yourself
it has present authoring which helps you
write out your present and identify
flaws that you can work on figuring out
and improving and future authoring which
helps you make a plan for the future
with code mp you get 10 off it's self
authoring.com
and this is a really good thing for
people who are trying to organize
themselves to improve
if you don't have a goal you have
nothing to aim for this helps fix that
it's also like
30 or less with my code so
it's cheap for what it is i think he
underpriced it but it's before i was
doing business negotiations
i hope he doesn't watch this
self-authoring.com code mp
remember to subscribe also i have a
clips channel at michaela peterson clips
linked below
enjoy the episode and if you want jbp
merch he has some on his website at
jordanb
peterson i'm raising my shoulder so this
doesn't
okay also if you want jbp merch
he has some on his website at
jordanbpeterson.com
these illustrations this is rule five
do not do what you hate this is
epic you can get these in poster form
jordan v peterson.com under shop
i want merch for myself i want a barbie
t-shirt it's happening folks
enjoy this episode remember to hit
subscribe if you like it
[Music]
jordan peterson welcome to my podcast
thanks mick it's good to have you here
thank you
it's good to be here too i thought it
would be fun
because you've been out of the public
eye for
a very long time my electronic avatars
are still out there working away
this is true this is very true um but i
thought a good way of kind of
bringing you back in an easy way would
to be a to do a q a
kind of type thing yep so you're okay
with that
yep cool so i asked my audience on
instagram
they're a handy bunch what kind of
questions and i was overloaded with
questions
and there seemed to be like a couple of
categories but i'm going to start with
like
some of the common ones that people
asked okay so let's start well first of
all the main question was
how are you doing i'm alive
you look alive yeah how am i doing i'm
functioning at about 20 percent i would
say
which is a lot better than one percent
yeah but it's not
good and then the last podcast we did
you were in worse shape could be okay
okay we're not gonna dwell on that very
much let's do some questions
um these are these are fun ones advice
what advice do you have for a young man
in his twenties
it's a pretty non-specific question make
a plan
look at what you're interested in get
disciplined about something
allow for the possibility that you have
something important to contribute to the
world
and that the world would be a lesser
place without that contribution
don't be afraid of taking on
responsibility you're so
it's where you find what sustains you in
your life
you can take on too much responsibility
you you have to be cautious in that
regard but
that's a less common problem than not
taking on enough
a lot of the things that people regard
as traps are actually
the means to their life you know often
young people
are afraid of commitment for example in
the context of a romantic relationship
and
because they feel that that's going to
interfere with their pursuit of
something more valuable but that's just
not the case is you're not going to find
something more valuable in your life
than a committed relationship with
someone that you love
that sustains itself across time and
that in all likelihood
produces children that's life and
there may be people for whom
avoiding that is the better route but
those people are very rare and
you need a real reason to assume that
you're one of those people
and hopefully for you you're not um
you know i've had a very good career a
very meaningful career
in multiple dimensions and it's still
been the case for me that the most
important part of my life
has been my intimate relationship with
my wife and my
and my family so don't be afraid of that
or be afraid of it but don't let that
stop you from from pursuing it
what about like how how much do people
have to kind of date around to find
somebody though because it does take a
bit of exploration to find somebody
you're compatible
with so what's a reasonable amount of
exploration and like by what age should
people have
figured it out because i mean there's
always the grass looks greener
so at some point maybe you should just
settle down but what are your thoughts
on that
well life isn't very long and so you
don't get
to evaluate that many relationships you
probably only have a five to ten year
period to do that something like that
and then
the reason you only have that amount of
time is because it gets more and more
difficult as you get older rather than
easier
partly because people your age are
increasingly in relationships
so i would say get at it don't don't
overestimate the degree
to which you have to find someone versus
create the relationship you know there's
many cultures and i'm not
i'm not suggesting that this is
necessarily a desirable alternative
there are many cultures that arrange
marriages and those arranged marriages
frequently work
it's not obvious that they work less
frequently than relationships or
marriages that are predicated on
romantic attraction which has its own
pitfalls
is that no matter who you find they're
going to be full of flaws like you are
and so a lot of it is something you
create
i think you want to find someone you can
trust and someone that you're attracted
to
and perhaps someone who shares the same
ambitions as you do or at least
has ambitions that are compatible with
yours and then
well then pretty much all of it after
that is what you create rather than what
you find
is part of the reason that arranged
relationships or arranged marriages work
is part of it because there's a societal
pressure to not get divorced
and because it's somebody your parents
have chosen um
there might be an expectation that
you're supposed to uphold of course
i mean that's partly why marriages in
the west work too are marriages and
cultures where
the primary impetus for the marriage is
romantic or sexual attraction
part of the reason those marriages works
is because work is because of social
pressure
it it's very difficult to sustain a
relationship across time
and you need all sorts of social
institutions
as well as conceptual schemes operating
to help ensure that that's the
case because life is so difficult you're
going to go through periods of time
where your relationship is
extraordinarily difficult but
there's no escaping that and if the
pressure
to stay together wasn't there the
relationship might fragment
prematurely and then not only would you
have your problems you'd also not have
any relationships
and that's not helpful so you go through
thick and thin
together and it can be very thin the
thin times can be very thin
but the the collective judgment of the
human race so far has been that
long-term monogamous relationships
are the best that you can manage and
that's true cross-culturally
with there are exceptions polygamy is
is relatively common nowhere near as
common as monogamy
but there are exceptions made for
polygamy
but the problem with polygamous
societies is that they tend to be more
violent especially
the young men in them tend to be more
violent because they are more shut out
of the mating
game and that makes them very frustrated
oh that makes sense
so it'd be mostly yeah that makes sense
that'd make me pissed off too
why is this what's this guy over here
have seven wives
he'd be better off dead yes yes and i
might be the one to
help him along with that yeah i mean
that's
part of what monogamy does is stabilize
societies and that means that fewer
stable in stable societies fewer people
die
and so all things considered
our species has decided that that's a
good trade-off
life's too hard i tried to do i tried to
do it
by myself for a while
it was hard like i my problem i might
have needed some time
to be by myself to learn what it was
like to be by myself
it's possible that i made a terrible
mistake which
were both well you were even when you
were by yourself though you had friends
and you had family
yeah but it is like life's easier if you
can find somebody who you're
compatible with with you've been like a
little bit compatible yes well it's it's
it's also something there's something to
be said
about sharing your experiences with
someone they're more real then
and
your past and your present and your
future all more real if you have someone
who shares them with you so advice for i
said advice for a mid-20s
man but that's more advice for just
young people in general is a big well
the best advice that you can really give
to people who are young is that
unless you have very good reason not to
you should do what
all people have always done and so what
does that mean i
when i see my clinical clients although
i'm not practicing anymore when i saw my
clinical clients i would
evaluate their lives across a number of
dimensions
um did would were they immersed in the
network of friendships
did they have a family and that could be
their family of birth but also
the family that they've produced their
own husband or wife and children
if they were of an age where that was
appropriate
did they have a career or at least a job
and
was their job productive and
um match well with their abilities and
their ambitions
were they educated to the extent that
their intelligence and curiosity might
demand
um were they in reasonable physical and
mental health
independent of those other areas all of
those things need to be
established and you don't want to
question them so much that you don't
establish them you might think of
yourself as a rebel and someone who's
particularly unique and
it's also it's also possible that you
are unique in one or more ways but
but fundamentally speaking
if you don't do what everyone else does
then
the probability that you're abdicating
your responsibility and that you will
miss out on something important is
extremely high
so you know our culture virtually every
movie that's made for children now you
see this coming out of the disney
studios constantly always concentrates
on
the special child who's got abilities
that no other child has and is being
crushed by society
into being um you know unpleasantly
normal and and and
there is a fair bit of crushing that
goes along with being socialized
because part of being socialized is to
become like everyone else
but you don't want to um underestimate
the benefit of that
it's it's very very difficult to tread
your
own path and you're only going to be
able to do that
in a limited number of areas you blow
apart
the social routines you'll find yourself
out there in
a domain of chaos that will overwhelm
you and that's not pleasant you do not
want that
you talked about socializing and i had a
few parents reach out and i haven't
actually thought about this but you talk
about how
kids have to be socialized by the age of
four or they're basically screwed
and right now that's true more true with
some kids than others so
okay there's a minority of children who
are quite aggressive by temperament at
the age of two
and if they're not socialized out of
that higher than
average level of of aggression by the
age of four
there isn't any evidence that that can
be rectified later
now that may have implications for other
elements of socialization as well it's
certainly the case that
you want your children to be acceptable
to their peers by the time they're three
and four
because peers do most of the
socialization here here's the problem
right now though
like i mean take toronto for existence
everyone's in lockdown you're not even
allowed to go to elementary school right
now
yeah so i have i had a couple of parents
reach out and they're like we've heard
about socializing our kid is so
like they're alone at home um so
other than the fact that i personally
think lockdowns are ridiculous
what do people do right now if they're
missing out on those developmental like
two to four
years like are there things you could
recommend they do are there things their
parents could do with them perhaps that
they can play with them and ensure that
the children have time to play
and you can be a reasonable replacement
for a play partner for your child
not entirely but most parents know how
to play with their kids and it's
very very important for children to play
so if your children don't have other
children to play with then you play with
them
they need to play okay so um
and you remember too the children are
very resilient
um so i wouldn't jump to the conclusion
that they're going to be permanently
damaged by this period of relative
deprivation
especially if they have parents who care
for them and who are doing what they can
to
keep them on the proper track so to
speak
during this terrible pandemic
plus everyone's going to be a little
stunted after the last couple years
and hopefully we're all equally stunted
come out a little dizzy
like did you feel behind in your
development yeah yeah well me too but
we're both two years behind so yeah
right
hopefully uh okay well that's good
advice
focus on like take seriously the
part of your life because you hear you
hear some people and they say
especially to men the 20s your 20s is
for learning
going to university getting a job
getting experience you can focus on
relationships
later like i've heard a lot of men's i
don't know if you'd call them like men's
rights activists or what
online say like you push the
relationship off because you can do that
later
well i think there men have more freedom
to do that than women do
because the biological clock ticks more
urgently for women
and i think it is the case that men
become more attractive through their 20s
rather than less
all things considered because they
become more competent and
so i think and if you look
cross-culturally again
women tend to find men who are about
four years older than them
optimally attractive all other things
held equal i mean there's lots of things
that each gender finds attractive or
unattractive about the other so i'm not
trying to say that
age is the only consideration but men
tend to prefer younger partners and
women
tend to prefer older partners and the
gap seems to be three to four years and
that does seem to be stable
cross-culturally
and so men do have that additional time
and they can use that additional time to
make themselves more attractive and they
basically do that
by making themselves more probable more
competent and
more generous i would say and that's a
good combination competent and generous
so and and women are appreciative of
that and
the fundamental reason they're
appreciative of that i believe is
because
women bear the primary responsibility
for early child care
certainly during pregnancy obviously and
then i would say for at least the first
year afterwards when
breastfeeding is and and when the child
is so dependent and
and so tied to the mother primarily
because of breastfeeding but not only
because of that
women need to find a partner to help
them redress that imbalance
and that's reasonable so
they look to men for the kind of
competence and generosity that allows
for the possibility of infant care
taking during that extraordinarily
dependent time and given she begs
ideally well that would be a marker for
that kind of competence possibly
uh um the first time
andre got me a givenchy bag and i
pronounced it gavinchi
oh yeah you did that did that decrease
your attractiveness in his eyes
i don't think he knows the difference
luckily but
uh the store clerk didn't say anything
they didn't even blink
they're like of course this way okay i'm
quite embarrassed about that as your
father
i don't think the camera will catch it
but i definitely turned a more healthy
shade
of color i should also tell people that
the the scientific
research the academic research that i
found most
credible with regards to male female
differences
has been derived from biology and
evolutionary psychology
david buss's work particularly and so
there's all sorts of academic schools
that purport to describe
gender or sex similarities and
differences but
the more biologically oriented
fields and modes of analysis produce the
most reliable results as far as i'm
concerned
so you may disagree with that for
example if you're one of
the people who believe that gender roles
and sex rules are entirely socially
constructed
then you're going to be unhappy with my
biological but generally well you
that be that as it may it's clearly the
case that sex and gender roles are
socialized to a large degree but
there's a big difference be between a
large degree and entirely
and i think you're a fool if you don't
pay attention to the role of biology
which is not to say that the biological
interpretation is necessarily free from
all bias but the scientific method is
pretty good at eradicating bias across
time it's also not to say that you're
you're
if you're a woman that you're gonna be a
girly woman like i'm i'm not a girly
like i am in some aspects girly but i'm
also very career oriented and i'm very
disagreeable
and i have male personality traits
right so like it's not like just because
there are differences doesn't mean you
have to be put
in the barbie category versus like
there are more similarities between men
and women across the
dimensions of personality for example
then there are differences
so on average women and men are more the
same than they are different
that means the curves the distributions
of the traits overlap to a large degree
but that doesn't mean that the
differences are trivial there was a new
study published this week
which i tweeted showing yet once again
that as cultures
become more egalitarian in their social
policies that occupational choice
differences between the sexes increase
rather than decrease and
that's actually a consequence of not of
of differences in interest that aren't
immense they're on the order of one
standard deviation
which is a large difference all things
considered but
still allows for retention of the truth
that there is more similarity between
men and women than difference
the thing is is that a lot of activity
occurs at the extremes and so
even minor differences uh can produce
very
in in base rates can produce very
different very great differences in
social outcome
for example men are more aggressive than
women
more physically violent let's say and
that's about half a standard deviation
indifference something like that
um and so you might say that the average
man
um the average man would be
more aggressive than something between
65 and 80 percent of women
something like that um but what that
translates into a massive difference in
incarceration rates
because the only people who get
incarcerated are the most
aggressive individuals and almost all
the most aggressive individuals are men
that makes sense i did um it makes sense
but people don't like it and it causes a
tremendous amount of controversy
well that's because it's slightly more
complicated than an elevator pitch
and anything that's more complicated
than an elevator pitch
well it's also because it's somewhat
contradictory you know it's not easy to
understand how
at one level of analysis things can be
essentially the same and at another
level of analysis they can be markedly
different
but you have to accept a couple of
presuppositions and for example with
regards to occupational choice
it's a very it's a minority of people
who become engineers
now engineers tend to be interested in
things rather than people
and more men than women women men on
average are more interested
in things than women on average and the
the difference it's actually the largest
sex difference that's known measurable
sex difference the known is
is that's known is interest in people
versus interest in things
but it's large enough so that it
produces a a
tremendous uh difference in the rates of
women for example even mathematically
gifted women who end up in engineering
or physics for that matter
so it seems somewhat independent of
ability which is also quite interesting
yeah that's true um i did i put up a
post today
and i remembered going to a class that
you taught where you mentioned
and then i looked up the study and it
was every 16 i don't know why they did
16 iq points
there's slightly above it's about a
standard deviation approximately
every 16 iq points a woman goes up from
100 she's
40 percent less likely to get married
and every 16 iq points a man goes up
from 100 he's 35 percent
more likely to get married and i i
didn't i couldn't remember the exact
statistics
and i wanted to post it so i googled it
but
that's hard to argue with i did and it's
like i remember hearing that i was
sitting in on one of your classes
because i don't know why
maybe it was summer time or something or
i wasn't going to probably a punishment
i'd arranged for you
it probably was but because i think i
had classes at the time
i don't anyway i was there and i
remember hearing that being like
this is bad this is bad news
yeah well it might be that i don't know
and this is pure speculation but
i don't think it's unreasonable to point
out that pursuing a career and a family
is more difficult for women than it is
for men and again i think that's because
of the
differential commitment during pregnancy
and for the first couple of years and so
it might be that more intelligent women
have a harder time because they're more
interested perhaps
in in a broad range of of they have a
broader range of interests
and perhaps of abilities it's less
obvious to them how to reconcile that
with
the more traditional maternal role
and i i don't know like it's speculation
that seems like pretty
you were being careful there that was
pretty i think that was pretty on point
i've been talking to people
um on my podcast about
some really successful people who have
kids
you know and i've been saying like how
do you do it or how if it's a man like
how does your wife do it how does she
have businesses and have
kids sorry there's another reason too
which i should point out is that
women tend to prefer men
at or above their position in social
hierarchy
and you could think of that as a
hierarchy of power which i think is
inappropriate or you could think about
it as a hierarchy of competence and so
a high iq woman is going to want a man
whose iq is as high as hers or higher
whereas a man men aren't like that
they they'll marry across and down the
the competence hierarchy
and so what that means is that as a
woman becomes more competent which would
include intellectually competent
her pool of eligible
mates from her perspective shrinks
there's just fewer men like that so if
you're a woman with an iq of 145
the only men you're going to be
interested in obviously these are over
generalizations but all other things
being equal are men with an iq of 145
and above and
that's like one percent of the
population
so and they might shrink they might like
the
110 or 120 iq
woman with big boobs that's 23. well
i don't know
you know you could you could you could
give men credit and say that they're
willing to take care of someone
and that's indexed by their preference
for
women who are at or below them in the
competence hierarchy
however you define that or you could say
that they don't like to be threatened in
their domain of competence by their
partner
they don't like feeling insecure and
inferior and
perhaps both of those are true and
perhaps neither of them and something
else entirely is true but
i think that makes sense i think both
could be true to a good degree i mean
if you end up being smarter than you're
as a woman i think if you end up being
smarter than your significant other and
you're challenging
them all the time then it does take away
from the kind of dominance
aspect that you that you find attractive
in a relationship so that makes it
difficult too yes
and that they probably find attractive
in in the relationship as well being the
dominant guy and if you're constantly
being like well here's why you're dumb
then that's not going to go well well i
think it's also
we don't want to underestimate the
degree to which
men are also intimidated by women who
are
outstanding across multiple dimensions
so men are certainly intimidated by
women who are very physically attractive
um
so then if you take a woman who's very
intelligent and very physically
attractive then
she's going to be a very intimidating
target and fewer men in all likelihood
are going to
approach her so
okay what about so we we kind of did
advice
for young people in their 20s i would
say
um do you have any specific
well the other thing i might advise that
this is more i said make a plan
yeah um i've developed a program with my
colleagues
at selfauthoring.com and there's a
program there called the future
authoring program and
it helps it's designed to help people
make a plan for their life across
multiple dimensions and
it's worked for me it's worked for many
people they're
i'm not saying that you should go out
and buy it but it's there and
you are saying that it works really well
and it's not very expensive it's like 25
no it's hard work though yeah but it's
not as hard work as stumbling blindly
through your life and failing
continually
it is hard though you have to write out
like it gets you to focus on your
problems it makes you think about a plan
it's kind of like doing homework like
if you're really if you want something
that's
pleasing really quickly it's going to be
tricky but it definitely
helps you organize your brain and try
and make a future plan especially if
you're one of those people that are
super open
and everything seems like a good idea oh
i could go in this direction could be a
lawyer
i could be an astronaut that was me i
could be a makeup artist that sounds
great mm-hmm
maybe i wanna maybe wanna do physics oh
no no i'm not smart enough for that
uh okay let's do a like i like the
family aspect but let's do
a 180. um
two questions one what are your thoughts
on
biden being in power but more
importantly
there are a lot of conservatives out
there that were
very pro-trump and i think a lot of them
don't know what to do now
and they don't know whether to feel
angry
or lost or if they start supporting
biden that they're you know that they're
doing something wrong
so i guess first question is do you have
recommendations for
conservatives now about what they should
do now that they don't have a
conservative leadership
well the only recommendation i would
have and i don't have any
particular i wouldn't claim any
particularly
brilliant ability in this area let's say
um
you'll get your chance again i mean one
of the things you can be sure of in the
democratic society is that
power flips back and forth between
people of difficult different
political persuasion and i think all
things considered
it might be best to have some faith in
that process now you might say that your
faith has been badly shaken by the
events of the last four years and
i think people feel that across the
political spectrum and that's a very bad
thing but
i have more faith in the institutions
all things considered
get your house in order that that's my
advice generally to people
rather than concentrating if you're a
conservative rather than concentrating
on what
the democrats have done wrong or the
people on the left you might concentrate
on what
your crowd and you are doing wrong and
try to stop doing that and
hope that that works i don't know
i'm not saying that will necessarily
work but i don't know a better
alternative
i have a good alternative potentially
okay so if everything goes
completely sideways even more than now
i think that we could just make a fund
and get a whole bunch of people in it
and take a whole bunch of money and buy
an island and just move there
and who do you mean by we um i can head
it because you'll get a lot of flack
uh uh well all the people on the island
immediately
we could do a community yeah and we'd
immediately fragment into
warring groups we'd also need a lot of
like lambs
yeah and cows and that'd be most of the
island
yeah it would definitely i'd get a tribe
right away
like i invited those people and they
were not like i thought they were
so they're off the island there's always
that option though if things go
completely
sideways yeah they're a little bit
sideways now they're a little sideways
but everybody is very stressed by the
lockdown and the pandemic and so
i'm hoping across time that that cooler
heads will prevail
so that means we should each try to cool
our heads i would say
uh how do you feel about you talked like
in in 2016 2017
2017 2018 i guess you talked about like
the importance of
free speech and
things have gone sideways way more since
then everyone was running around in 2018
thinking things were going badly and
then
boom but uh how do you feel about
the tech like kind of
the i guess the power that certain tech
companies have right now
social media companies i should say well
i'm ambivalent about it in in many ways
i
i mean i don't think it's a good thing
that
our society is now organized so that
private companies that that control
and allow for a tremendous amount of our
interpersonal communication
have the power or have been forced into
the position
where they're policing speech now maybe
that's inevitable when you produce a new
communications technology
um it's obvious that that can go
dreadfully wrong
i wish i had a simple solution to it i i
have a social media platform
um i own some of it think spot
and it's not there aren't millions of
people using it and no doubt we're going
to run into policing problems and
it isn't obvious to me how those can be
solved they're solved by people trying
to be
by people at the individual level
attempting to be as reasonable as they
possibly can
even in their online discourse but
there's going to be
people who are unreasonable on purpose
and people who are unreasonable by
accident and
it's not obvious how that can be dealt
with or where the line should be drawn
so um
people who are unreasonable who are
running things well the
the free speech proponents can say well
if you're a private company you don't
have the obligation to host
the opinions of people with whom you do
not agree and you know i have some
sympathy for that uh perspective if i
i wouldn't like it if my social media
platforms
were forced to open themselves up to
just anyone's opinion
you know
i wish i had a simple solution for it
um with think spot we had promised that
we wouldn't take down any contributions
that weren't that didn't violate or
appear to violate
american law um that's a reasonable
restriction since
as long as you assume that the law is
reasonable but i don't have any words of
wisdom other than that
it's it's frightening to see what's
happening
it's disturbing to see what's happening
with d
platforming and and so forth but
but what's the solution that's right
what's the solution yeah and it's funny
you hear
like when uh
so trump got kicked off of twitter uh
and everything else
and conservatives were generally up in
arms about that because they're like
that's
terrifying which i agree it's scary um
but then there's this antifa group got
kicked off of twitter and they were like
yeah they should have been kicked off a
long time ago
not to compare trump to antifa
necessarily but
those are the same people saying well
private companies should be able to do
whatever they want which i agree with
well they're not necessarily the same
people that's the other thing that's so
strange about social media is that you
can get groups of people who are
hypothetically allied by their political
beliefs saying opposite things at the
same time but
even if you're united with other people
by your political belief
all the people within that union are
still extraordinarily diverse and are
going to have all sorts of diverse
opinions
so is it ever acceptable to cancel
somebody
is there like is there a line or you
said american law
well it's always the case that these
things have to be
thought through in their specific
instantiations and
i'm i'm i'm often parodied for my
answers to questions like this but
it depends on what do you exactly mean
by cancel
like it's clearly the case that there
have been instances where people have
been
fired or blocked off social media
without perhaps with without
sufficient um provocation
so but it's the same question again
at what point does misbehavior mount to
the
amount to the degree that something that
intervention has to occur
and we don't know how to answer that we
don't know how to regulate these new
technologies
they're too complicated and
sophisticated and
that they're beyond us in some ways i
mean twitter for example seems to
promote
irritable responses and impulsive
responses and that's probably
in part because of its strict character
limit you have to react
you know with with short bursts of of of
thought
so there's no nuance well the the room
for nuance is limited and
you could your anger systems can produce
short outbursts
short verbal outbursts and so it's
an unexpected consequence of that
strange limitation in communication
perhaps that twitter tends to be an
impulsive forum
we just don't understand enough about
human psychology to
predict that sort of thing much less
police it we have no idea what
effects on personality like what's the
effect on personality
of being forced to communicate in in
bursts of less than 280 characters
no one knows the answer to that maybe
maybe
that brings your disagreeable aspect out
to the forefront in a way that a longer
post just wouldn't that seems you know
maybe compassion takes 500 words and
500 characters and anger takes 180. no
one knows
that seems logical well
anger is an impulsive response an
impulsive immediate response and so
it's likely adapted to shorter time
frames
i've thought about it a lot because i'm
generally
i'm i'm generally of the opinion of just
like leave let people have the most
freedom they can
don't impose rules right but social
media was tricky because
it's a private company and i wouldn't
want my company to have random rules put
on it by the government
right more than that's already happening
but i think these social media
giants are so big that they can't be
treated
as a private company anymore i think
maybe once you have a certain maybe it's
that what to have a certain number of
users
there are guidelines that i don't know
who would even make these that's that's
part of the issue but maybe the
guidelines are the law
and that it just switches over to that
because twitter like
everybody's on twitter everybody's on
facebook it's
the government at some point right at
some point a public company becomes
a utility infras part of the utility
infrastructure
and at that point it seems to emerge in
some ways beyond the merely private
domain
i do think something like that's the
case but exactly when that happens
and you know people have used the
example of telephone companies though
for example everybody uses the telephone
but nobody polices the content now with
a phone
i mean the old phone when you were just
speaking with someone
you couldn't influence a million people
with one utterance
so the phone was one on one and its
danger was constrained at least in part
by that but now
a single utterance on you know a major
influencer's part can
be broadcast to a couple of million
people multiple times a day
i do think that at some point
private companies provide services that
are so ubiquitous that
they become public necessities and that
new rules need to govern
yeah but that's what i think too i don't
know who would make the rules because i
also don't trust the guy the governments
would make the government
governments would make the rules and the
reason for that is we don't have a
better mechanism than that
yeah but i mean maybe the old rules you
don't want whoever's in power to
suddenly dictate all the social media
companies
that could easily be a disaster well you
do if you don't have a better option
right we don't have a better
decision-making alternative for
large-scale public
decisions than government that's
terrible now
well yes and no there's always the
commune well
the government has its role and private
enterprise has its role and they balance
each other to some degree and so
it's very balanced at the moment things
are
like not good right now i know you can
be all optimistic and things but
i just i'm gonna make a video about this
but like i told you yesterday i just
found out that
it's mandated that you give birth in a
mask even
if you've been vaccinated and are
negative can you see that ever going
away
no like i don't think things are very
good right now maybe things will
magically get better when everyone's
vaccinated and the death rate plummets
i suspect that will improve things a lot
but and i don't think that we should
make the mistake of assuming that our
current
surreal reality is
what we're going to experience for the
long run but even in
even in places in asia after they got
hit with stars masks became a fashion
staple
they just warm they just wear masks
i don't i certainly have no specific
ability to see
where this is headed nobody does and we
don't know how effective the vaccines
will be or how the
virus will mutate i'm optimistic about
the vaccines i think they'll bring them
under
bring the epidemic under control quite
rapidly
so god i hope so and like i said there's
always the communion option
right things go completely sideways okay
yes well people tried that a lot in the
60s and it never did work
i wasn't around in the 60s i don't
remember that
uh plus there were a lot of psychedelics
involved in that right
people were a little too naked like
maybe there'd probably be a lot of that
involved in any common you were a part
of two
yeah they're probably okay um to
do a 180. i don't think we've talked
about this before but what are your
thoughts on
this is philosophical free will versus
not having any free will do you even
care determinism determinism yeah
well it's not an either or a proposition
you're free in some regards and
determined in others and
the farther out you look in the future
as far as i can see
the farther out you look in the future
the more your behavior is
is is free will like and the closer it
is to the present the more your behavior
is determined so for example
oh i like that if you make a ballistic
movement so if i move my hand rapidly
from here to here
and stop it i i dis-inhibit that
movement
and it's ballistic once the movement
starts i have no free will once i've
initiated the movement i can't react
fast enough to stop my hand i have to
pre-plan that
using unconscious mechanisms beforehand
and then allow the program to run
and so as you move towards an action you
become increasingly determined
so that i wrote a paper on that
years ago a student of mine was the
first author um
a good enough theory of free will i
believe it was called
um you can look that paper up on the
online i'll link it yeah i'll link it in
show notes um
i'm embarrassed to say i can't remember
the name of the first author
he's a professor now i believe it in a
university in british columbia
it may come to me soon a good enough
theory of free will
um and we we attended the guys there
with a j
don't remember okay i know that's not
that useful anyway
you attempted to yeah well we treat each
other as if we have free will
and societies that are predicated on the
assumption that we have free will seem
to be functional societies and
when we observe our own behavior we
treat ourselves like we have free will
and we
reward and punish ourselves as if we
have free will and so
um i'm i'm not willing to dispense with
that
presumption given its high degree of
functionality
even though it's not easy to understand
how it might be the case
i think it may be that we have free will
because
we're actually too complex to be
determined
simple systems act in a determinate
manner but once they exceed a certain
level of complexity i don't think that
that's the case anymore
i don't know how to understand that
though i like that
that you can kind of aim to where you're
going and then you have
tons of options right especially if
you're looking at career or
or who you're going to marry maybe or
family or
you know big things career particularly
so you can aim but then yeah each action
you take
kind of leads to a limited number of
actions or maybe just one
realistically well it better because
otherwise you wouldn't be able to act
you actually want to constrain your
field of choices until you hit a
determined point because then you act
the obvious choice or or even the
inevitable choice
i mean obviously when you put your hand
on a stove you don't have any choice
about whether you
jerk it off and
and so that's that's a place where
you're determined in your response
there's reflex there's determinism at a
reflexive level
and a lot of your behavior is chained
reflexes but
that doesn't mean that you don't decide
where to aim those chained reflexes
um i i i've never really been i asked
the question because i
got interested in it for a second but
i've always kind of avoided that
conversation because i thought
honestly what difference does it make
say everything's determined
and and you could track where you're
going if you had enough information
right does that mean that you're going
to be a crappy person
if nothing if everything you do is
determined
right because people i find that the
problem with it is people can make the
excuse well if
it's out of my control and i have no
self-will then it's not my fault
kind of thing well and people do make
that argument and sometimes validly so
you can sustain forms of brain damage
that clearly impair your ability to make
moral choices
so if yeah damage
then you often become impulsive and
make choices that that are immoral
perhaps even by your own judgment before
you have the damage
so you can be unfortunate and end up in
a very determined condition and courts
do take that into account frequently
it looks like someone who's healthy and
and functioning
optimally has a high degree of free will
and someone who's ill and
is constrained has is
is not as free in their actions it's
reasonable to take that into account
yeah that's depressing but definitely
true you have very limited
a limited number of things you can do if
you're sick or even how you can think
right for sure if you're really sick yes
well it's almost the definition of
sickness apart from the pain and the
anxiety that it produces but those are
limitations as well
um what's the difference between so
you're coming out with a book
when is the publishing date march 2nd
beyond order 12 more rules for life so
what's the difference between
beyond order and your first 12 rules for
life
well the first one has a white cover and
the second one has a black cover that's
that's sold i'm sold
well the the first as the title
indicates
the first book was 12 rules for life an
antidote to chaos and the second book is
beyond order 12 more rules for life
i divided up a set of rules that i had
written for a website called quora
into two categories and the categories
essentially were
rules that pertain to how you to the
situation where too much uncertainty and
chaos ruled
and that and alternatively is the
situation where too much constraint and
order
reigned and those are two fundamental
conditions of existence you can be
swamped by chaos or you can be
over constrained by structure and order
and so
the first book was about how to deal
with an excess of uncertainty let's say
in the second book
is oriented more towards how you deal
with an excess of
constraint and i would say also if you
thought about it politically in some
sense the first book would be more
conservative
in its orientation in the second book
more liberal because
conservatives tend to be more
temperamentally
upset let's say by uncertainty and chaos
and liberals are more temperamentally
upset by
the excesses of the patriarchal
structure let's say i don't think that
necessarily would come as a surprise to
anyone
but each of those situations can get out
of hand do you think that's still
true i was talking to andre the other
day about
you know i i definitely used to identify
i was always kind of libertarian
it's like them i like i like those
people but probably more liberal and
then
and now i'm certainly more on the
conservative side even though
i'm not i even though that word doesn't
make sense to me
right like if i'm talking about
psychedelics how can i be a conservative
like that doesn't make sense so do you
think nowadays
conservatives are still the people who
are less open
i think your question might be more
where do the libertarians fit do they
fit on the liberal side of the
conservative side and you might be
making the case that the libertarians
have now
shifted towards the conservative side
okay i don't know if that's
if it's changed the personality
predictors of liberalism and
conservatism
and i don't know if the underlying
political order has that would be
interesting to figure out
because do you do you have the
personality indicators for liberals
versus sure
liberals are higher liberals are higher
in openness but that was from
10 years ago 15 years ago that might be
something like that
i'm curious i suspect it's i mean i
suspect it's still the same
but i don't know for sure then how can
like it it feels to me just from looking
at the political spectrum and maybe this
is wrong and this is the view i get but
it feels to me that it's the liberal
people who are putting rules
in now well i think that it may be that
something shifts in political belief
near the extremes
i mean it's not like i don't i certainly
believe there are left-wing
totalitarians
that's true but the the rules
the rules that apply at the extremes
might not be the same rules that apply
in the middle
and maybe so and then the question is
how should the middle deal with the
extremes and i actually think that
that's the question that
that bothers us politically right now
how do the liberals control the radical
left wingers and how do the
conservatives moderate conservatives
control the radical right-wingers
now i've been more concerned
as an academic with the actions of the
radical left-wingers because
they've produced more of what i see as a
threat to free academic inquiry
how that's playing out on the broader
social sphere isn't self-evident to me i
feel like it's fairly self-evident well
perhaps it is
i think so but i'm a disagreeable human
being
didn't we pat didn't you and andre told
me that you guys passed a playground the
other day that said play inclusively on
it yeah
that sounds like 1984. but yeah
it was i wasn't very happy with the
signage yeah
wow you're welcome in the psychedelic
commune
[Music]
you